Congress is turning its attention to
passing a new round of stimulus funding
directed that economic damage done by
coated nineteen
this could include additional cast
payments for Americans and aid for state
and local governments there's a
bipartisan understanding that more help
is needed even after Congress passes two
trillion dollar stimulus bill last month
some Democratic proposals are calling
for more payments to Americans with one
for as much as $2,000 a month and one
Republican senator Josh Hawley is
calling for Congress to help businesses
cover worker wages until the crisis ends
financial aid to state and local
governments has become a contentious
issue the National Governors Association
has been pushing for five hundred
billion in state aid House Speaker Nancy
Pelosi has promised state and local
governments will receive funding in the
next coronavirus package in a quote very
significant way but Senate Majority
Leader Mitch McConnell has been vocal
about his reluctance by assistance to
States even suggesting states could
declare bankruptcy instead and president
Trump argued federal dollars should not
go to Democratic run states and cities
and even proposed funding could be tied
to their sanctuary city policies the
Center on Budget and Policy Priorities
estimates state budget shortfalls from
Cova nineteen economic fallout could
total six hundred and fifty billion over
three years James McCann a senior
economist at Aberdeen standard
Investments says he does not believe
being squeamish about death is the right
move at this time I'd actually say that
the more you do now the greater the
chance actually that you save money in
the long term both in terms of being
able to deal with the crisis more
quickly engineer a better and stronger
more durable recovery make sure the
economy in the long term is large or
that tax base is larger my fear is
you're starting to see this debate start
to happen about concerns around long to
have that position of the United States
and the financing of that you know and
that's really something that we saw set
here not long after the financial crisis
and during that episode it meant that
fiscal policy actually tightened not too
long after that from 2010 onwards we saw
a swing back in fiscal policy and we
think that did a lot of damage
that the recovery was slower and bumpy
that he needed to be
what Kunal has also said he won't
support infrastructure spending in the
next round of relief funding this is
despite both president Trump's and the
Democrats support of it still one thing
is clear with news at the economy shrank
by 4.8% last quarter its biggest
contraction since the Great Recession
lawmakers will face presser to support
more aid as soon as possible